brought to you by PlayStation Store
access to the ultimate and games and
entertainment ebony fine gentleman Brad
Muir and the one and only dvz Dave Lang
is here one thing has changed since the
last intro like Alexander was here yeah
yeah you describe that group is handsome
yeah steps out I step in the fine
gentleman yeah yeah if we're I mean why
are you in gentlemen technically he's
double fine gentlemen so it's kind of
calves from both you guys never been
madder than I am right now that's what
happens you you wear an old Miss cap
onto our show not angry you see this you
see his face which camera funny is it
not out in there you know yeah oh that
is beautiful oh yeah zero now the
trolley transitional oh [ __ ] we got
ourselves a thumbnail all of you fine
gentlemen thank you actually what I do
want to talk to you guys about is that
some news came out earlier the Mad Max
the video game she's not associated with
either the film or the old film or any
sort of Mad Max play or book or anything
to disassociate with my remarks it's
coming out at September first actually
same day as metal gear solid ground zero
out of programming exactly a different
right open open worlds I have not seen
this yet this is great and so video game
experts on the couch having not seen
this trailer before but they also
announce that they've dropped the
previous gen version so they were really
gonna make a ps3 and xbox 360 version of
this bad boy as well I want to ask you
guys as gentlemen who are part of making
games for consoles and what not at what
stage do you sort of look at the numbers
and go you know what the previous gen is
dead all of our customers on the new
stuff we're not gonna put any more
resources into working on on those
consoles and it's different for some
like Mad Max where you've got like
physical goods you have to buy an
inventory and keep stuff we're doing
there's none of that so yeah if you can
keep the dev cost super low there's no
reason not to because we're our cogs
right yeah talk snap off goods cost of
goods yeah what's the cost of good cards
what is it what's it cost one of the
goods your friend your goody bag
older the annual physical stuff oh
really to get the actual disc into the
store and sell it and then pay those
people at store them and ship them in
RJ's it's like yeah it doesn't make
sense for there's a point where I'm
probably a long time ago or doesn't make
sense to do that Wow so the thought that
was a genuine like even with like the
sort of distribution channels presumably
being there like there is such a large
cost with getting stuff in to see what
he's like so city like you know cogs
every publisher has their own terms for
cogs but just say hypothetically they're
five dollars mm-hmm right on every game
yeah really if you make you know the
reprint three million if to spend 15
million digits to do that yeah and you
know company you're not gonna make that
back then why you know so it's a it's a
thing take a big a risk yes and also
with I think like though the really big
releases and the ones that the appeal to
the hardcore community like at this
point I guess we're like two years and
you know by September will be like two
years in the life cycle and that's like
most of the people that would give a
[ __ ] about that kind of game like a big
triple a kind of like thing they
probably moved on if you're gonna put it
out on the 360 xbox one it's like I most
of the people if they you know if
they're interested in and they probably
have an xbox one and they'll buy it
there like the cost of development to
kind of like scale everything down and
get it onto the old hardware and stuff
it's just gonna cost a bunch because
you're trying to like maximize the
current hardware and like blow it out
and just really try to make it of course
with a game like this yeah you're trying
to like just make it Lucas [ __ ] sweet
as possible and get get bump maps and
spec maps and get all this stuff on the
dudes and thing with a difference with a
bump in a spec man I don't know I
couldn't tell you that I knew it I can
tell by the way we're doing this all
guys like it's like a weird thing right
now yeah the bloody mess no happiness
that I killed it speculation games like
shadow of mordor right which its last
gen versions had like less features yeah
it wasn't just that the world was less
beautiful or less dingy as the case may
be like the Nemesis system couldn't be
as complex on the 360 ps3 version so at
that point like it's a diminishing
returns on that last what laughing is it
like you're not actually making the game
you want to be making you're making a
compromise
other people to have like a
significantly crappier experience on the
previous gen gen platform but there is I
mean women there viewer you renowned
around he doesn't say only thing I would
prefer the ps3 version yeah suck yeah we
can have a significantly crappier
version I'm agraphia true them how much
crappier can it be that's just gonna
spur them to buy the other one that's
the noise yeah that's what it took the
nipple for distances market and get
people to buy ps4 you're both developers
of games they're released digitally as
well was there as was there a sort of
time where the numbers were like okay
there are no people like comfortable
buying games digitally the weekend now
like release things only this way
because I guess it's probably more for
you Dave because like massive Chavez on
Steam and that's a you know a
tried-and-tested sorta system by this
day yeah but like creating an xbox one
game that was digital-only was that ever
like a warrior anything like figure like
the choice we had to make recently was
like divekick do we bring it to xbox one
and ps4 and you know that's going to
cost you have a time you're like I think
well so this many units and I think
it'll cost this much to do it he just
kind of like make the best educated
guess you can that's how projections
were to you just go I think we'll sell
this much will probably cost this much
do you have like and if this one is
bigger than this one and then we were
like you're like BAM we're doing it this
one the weird thing though is look at
that this Christmas Delta matter how the
girls you lose money so much its latest
things i toast this one's high last time
and now this one's hug and we watched
her ass both times record get it is all
i'll maybe she's not two variables oh
man do you guys have access like good
numbers for not to go for absolutely not
like sony don't say we've got like you
go by MP know you get away it's looking
specifically on significant you see
milly effectively shittier since it will
it'll be clearly well yeah cuz it's not
like I mean valve touts big numbers but
they're not like yeah we're just gonna
publish all the numbers on everything we
sell or and then the publishers like
they just you know they kind of hold on
to those digital immerse as well at
least when it was all physical you could
get the NPD's and they were like kind of
in the ballpark and it sort of made
sense that's before I knew kind of what
I was doing so do you think they're like
intentionally i do now crap this goes
whoops um but like yeah like I think
that's how when sort of back like in the
PS two days is that the numbers that you
had were a lot more reliable like you
think they're intentionally i would say
though that is not their position to
release those numbers that's mean
there's pilot pillar don't want those
numbers getting out area right so it's
not really their call but even as
somebody who's like you you know it has
a partnership with a console
manufacturer saying like we're making
this game for your machine would you
were they not like would you not have a
relationship there where you can be like
look this is how many weeks old this is
how many people bought fighting games in
you know for this console uh I mean
that's stuff useful for pitching for
stuff like if you're proposing the way
project like hey we think we want to
make a fighting game we think last one
we didn'ts platform sold this many the
budget of this we can easily recoup that
like that kind of way but it's all it's
it's all firsthand data you know it's
not like can go to the source or what
are you AC mail my friends and say hey
what's your game do on the Wii U or
three beta whatever right now and then
use cobbled together like okay here's
what a really good look at you don't
have been getting into comp here's what
everyone else did in that platform which
one do you think you're going to be also
and then you're like and then you're
like we're gonna be like a shovel Knight
because you're always like and the
reality is like well know what the
reality yeah remember the reality like
if this is the phils where you think
things are but burst is the reality the
reality thing you said you're as good as
you've ever been on never I gather the
reality is that just a dumbing I wanted
to a platform of excellence in all
things at all times okay a life is one
of Ascension
you